bonjour bertrand bonjour jimmy bonjour à
toutes et à tous un peu de retard ce
matin avec notre invité qui a eu un peu
de mal à trouver une place pour
stationner notamment patricia tel vous
êtes deuxième vice président de
l'assemblée de martinique également
présidente de la commission coopération
internationale donc vous avez participé
aux trois jours de conférences de
réunion des présidents de
région ultrapériphérique de l'union
européenne quels premiers enseignements
tirez vous à chaud de cette réunion au
sommet
bonjour à tous bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique la première alors tout
d'abord une grande satisfaction une
grande satisfaction d'avoir réuni les 9
rup
avec des délégations assez importante et
surtout le contenu de ces rencontres
je crois que nous avons la enfin nous
pensons avoir eu un moment historique
parce qu'il y à une convergence des
présidents des rup pour dire il faut
faire quelque chose et il faut le faire
maintenant pour vous c'est inédit il n'a
pas été le cas lors des précédents
sommets des précédentes rencontres il
écoute et nous nous nous avons
l'impression que que c'est inédit parce
que d'abord il y a comme un alignement
des planètes j'aime bien à
employer cette expression
le président serge letchimy a été donc
nommé président de la conférence des
présidents des rues en novembre 2021 et
il le sera jusqu'à novembre 2022 en même
temps depuis le début de l'année et
jusqu'au 30 juin la france préside donc
le conseil de l'union européenne donc
selon vous il ya un alignement des
étoiles que vous avez su saisir
oui et dont nous espérons bien que nous
profiterons et pour cela il faut que
l'état français il faut que le président
macron
soit bien à notre écoute et soit surtout
à nos côtés pour aller vers la
commission européenne que la balle est
maintenant dans son camp la balle est
dans son camp tout à fait et aux 38 au
soir ajustements de sa présidence du
conseil mais il fera la déclaration et
surtout la commission européenne donnera
sa décision par rapport à nos demandes
par rapport à ce que nous souhaitons et
en fait les rues parle d'une seule voix
nous avons beaucoup de difficultés
communes chaque région bien sûr est
différente donc parfois il y a des
spécificités mais nous partageons
d'énormes problèmes dont nous voulons
que la commission européenne tiennent
compte alors cette conférence des
présidents des rup qui s'est déroulé
donc cette semaine durant trois jours en
martinique correspond aussi à une
nouvelle stratégie de la commission
européenne a adopté il y a deux semaines
donc un peu avant la tenue de ce sommet
alors parmi les nouveautés présentées
pour cette nouvelle stratégie de la
commission européenne est bien en tout
premier lieu de donner la priorité aux
gens et à leurs besoins c'est ainsi que
sa formule et donnez la priorité aux
gens et à leurs besoins vous en avez
tenu compte dans vos travaux de cette
semaine au patricia tle absolument
absolument et les gens et leurs besoins
c'est la population c'est la situation
économique de notre île c'est la
situation des agriculteurs
c'est la situation des marins pêcheurs
oui nous avons nous en avons tenu compte
et pour cela nous avons non seulement eu
ces conférences en salle mais également
des visites sur le terrain et sur le
terrain il ya les gens il ya la
population il ya les ouvriers nous
sommes allés voir pas restons fermement
dénoncé en faire comme ça sur le roi la
sucrerie du galion aldiouma marins
pêcheurs au port de pêche de cosmi et
puis hier encore des des artisans qui
font de l'agroalimentaire
autre nouveauté dit la commission alors
que les rup sont reconnues c'est
souligner un reconnus comme des atouts
pour l'union européenne bon on pensait
que c'était déjà le cas depuis quelques
temps mais en quoi est ce important de
le souligner a à nouveau
ça fait peut-être allusion à ce que vous
disiez auparavant c'est peut-être que
c'est passé à l'esprit de certains
décideurs tant à paris qu'à bruxelles et
strasbourg strasbourg le le lieu du
parlement européen est cinglant alors
c'est écrit sur le papier on ne peut
ignorer l'article 349 du tfue du traité
de fonctionnement de l'union européenne
c'est écrit mais il faut vraiment mettre
en application concrètement ce qui est
écrit et nous sommes une richesse notre
biodiversité
la z de la zone économique européenne
que nous avons c'est une richesse en
fait nous avons une situation
géostratégique et donc il faut que
l'europe s'en rendent compte et c'est
pour cela aussi que nous voulons que non
seulement les dossiers soient traités
sur papier non seulement qu'il y ait des
visioconférences non seulement qu'il y
ait des échanges téléphoniques mais
qu'ils viennent qu'ils viennent autant
que possible et la commissaire
européenne qui étaient là et lisa
herrera a pu se rendre compte je crois
que nous avons besoin nous rup que
l'europe soit moins éloignés de nous et
ça c'est une c'est une demande commune
alors il y en a par exemple en début de
semaine quand j'ai interrogé le
président de la région guadeloupe ary
chalus il réclamait par exemple que dans
certaines circonstances ou dans des
rendez vous précis mais régulier les
régions ultra périphériques de l'union
européenne puisse quelquefois dialoguer
aussi directement avec les instances
européennes de là encore tant à
bruxelles qu'à strasbourg de ne pas à
chaque fois passer par le filtre en
quelque sorte par le biais est bien de
la france de la capitale de paris quoi
est-ce que ce dialogue un peu plus
direct tout en n'écartant pas
complètement évidemment l'état central
mais enfin est-ce que voilà c'est
peut-être aussi dans les tuyaux
absolument un sentier 30 secondes oui
c'est une demande commune 1 je dois vous
dire que c'est une demande commune il
faut que nous puissions parler il faut
assouplir il faut assouplir surtout pour
que le dialogue entre sommes donc entre
nous et la commission européenne puisse
passer voit la petite interruption pour
donc un flash
information et nous reprendrons avec
vous patricia tel cet entretien
agrémenté des questions des auditrices
et des auditeurs certainement